please shooting through glass now I mean
it's just [ __ ] if I [ __ ] 105 life
hacks 105 we are back again say hello
Johnny noose it from propane fitness are
here so life hacks is the most requested
episode that we do and it feels like the
lowest hanging fruit I reckon we could
just make another channel that's just
life hacks and definitely just do is a
full time although Johnny you seem to
think you don't have any no no I don't
you can't see you can't see the woods
and trees that's why you are so
optimized so I I don't the risk to the
groove too hard your threshold is low is
too low for life hacks though 6 Oh Chris
had too high too high
yep Chris had a dairy product on yes I
mean right yeah for how you try to open
up skully sure so Johnny have my some
I'm going to start having to categorize
these into like physical digital
financial and then different rooms but
my most recent one which I'm so excited
about is a shot buffer which is an
Arabic word before bum spray now I've
got one of these fits is go one of these
fitted in my bathroom recently 50 pounds
high pressure pump spray that just good
so right this is the justification for a
product like this everywhere east of
here everyone has a shot buffer but if
you like okay if you get a bit of poop
on your face you don't just go I'm gonna
get a bit of dry tissue paper and wipe
it off a couple of times there we go
that'll do like you'd wash it with
something and then you clean it and so
what about if there was gonna be more
poo coming from your face all the time
then you get some easy access spray that
you can just hose it down and then go so
I've seen the hose that you're talking
about
the pressure that comes out of it is a
bit terrifying you have to do you ever
find if you're too central with the
spray that you accidentally give
yourself an enema it's feasible yeah
like you have you relaxed
if you relaxed they rushed out yeah
what's that what's that what's relaxing
like that what's this like if you donate
Uranus then yeah yeah so the question is
what is the how much ring tension does
your sphincter have and what what water
pressure is required to make the valve
break yes it's great to go if you've got
a loose pelvic floor then yeah like then
imagine you pointed out your anus and
brusque oh dear yeah you do but directly
I've got quite your water pollutes it so
I think like that girl of Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory the blueberries
don't violence when it Viterbo Lagaan
yeah but yeah you can always pull the
reducing valve down a little bit if it's
too much yeah the other thing that I saw
someone gives them a life hack which i
think is just it's just a standard thing
is they were like ah spread your cheeks
when you go to the toilet like surely
everyone does that is the same as
squeeze one out from between clenched
butt cheeks yeah well I I lean forward
like well no one's like try not to try
and try and have it definitely don't try
and have a [ __ ] at the top of a deadlift
yeah my kisses so I think some like I
know we are saying your thresholds too
high but to some people your thresholds
too low well so I would I would take you
all sure tougher shot buffer Lassie
step back you can get but obviously
means if you know
so I was I was listening to a podcast
that Shane perished it from the
knowledge project is a guy behind Farnam
Street and I'm on that they said the
exact same thing that pretty much
everywhere east of here they use moist
toilet paper use mice and that way the
pay that's my normal mo if I'm outside
of shot buffers
is one modus operandi yeah wet to the
toilet paper what weight the toilet
paper you're totally right you would not
usually wipe something dirty with
something dry so that what I was saying
about taking a step back
why so you need there's so much wiping
were quiet that you need a pressurized
hose in your bathroom
why don't you green smoothies yeah like
remove remove the need ever we talked
about green Smith yeah I've done it but
you haven't talked about you haven't
talked about um why you shave your anus
I haven't in a long time this is
breaking about if I can juggle down
there now
it's alright so all of this is just it
just comes from I I think a Muslim
upbringing gives you an obsessional
level of toilet hygiene which is weird
because I was thinking about that the
funnier it is just thought another one I
just wanted just for a segue the last
time I looked at you surfs laptop during
one of these episodes was when we did
life hack fails which never made it on
the podcast but when I was reading his
list so it's one of the funniest things
I've ever read in my life but one of the
things it said was just joined a cult we
don't have to get onto that with my top
fails if you want if you want to hear
the life fails or one on one episode
comment below and he'll do it because
traffic because traffic because traffic
right go back Johnny go blah blah jomi
you go um well no um I'm reeling from
the a hygiene to be honest okay what is
it somali by probably might one of my
biggest tips of related to anal hygiene
is and this sounds so basic but it's
also a bit of a weird thing to say but a
lot of people talk to us about that
pivot like i have a lot of conversations
a lot of people about that poo and i
suppose we we tell people what to put
into their bodies yes so they think what
comes out is that is the product
that the easiest way to just make
pilling a brilliant experience like set
your watch by it just up your green
vegetables like 500 grams so akela
broccoli today I guarantee you won't
have any point you have to eat 500
crumbs to a group a kilo of broccoli
let's roll a bunch if you blend it down
as well like if you go to proofing
Fitness Tommy /qu this is not to pull on
that and say oh well talk to to show you
right up
so [ __ ] that's my tip fine okay cause
like it's overlooked but actually like
pooing can be a really horrendous thing
what was the Kelly Starrett
good if you wake up every morning with
an erection if your mum or we have a
penis wake up every morning with an
erection and have a pill every day then
you're probably quite healthy
physiologically hmm nothing to worry
about
hmm and that like as as sort of metrics
go I really like that but there's a
famous like old doctor you know when
doctors were like polymaths
mm-hm and that says that it has a quote
like there is nothing no greater
pleasure in this life than a good bowel
movement well sir I really agree and
it's also strange that anything making
anything go out of you feels fantastic
and there's very few I can't think of a
single exception to that
mmm-hmm let want it out just up you
green vegetable intake so dark leafy
green veggie just add it into your
should we move on from the whole on that
was my tip no yeah no first I think I
like my own self I like such an opening
bomb stuff yeah it is an opening or
according got any bumps up no I haven't
got any bump stuff so first one that I'm
gonna do is one thing bring you back
that's everyone do some okay everyone
who follows me online will know which is
eat Soren
not related to bomb stuff it will be it
will translate into bumps of Adventure
is about consequences it's a serene is
the is the brand yeah what what is sorry
so it's a malt loaf which is a fruit
love so you don't really make anything
else
no they just make more glowy making it
like a cake thing do I think so not sure
but we don't need to worry you do not
need to worry start off with anything
else that soaring me all you need to be
concerned about is the apple and Sultana
and but
Malta love so good example of how much
press likes this we came around here to
watch the CrossFit Games couple of weeks
ago mm-hmm or whatever point the past
when have you listened to this I bought
a few sleeves of mini ones thinking oh
there's plenty to go around
I think we had one each was a bit the
what about the games when it get one
might Chris where have they gone he
started I thought your favorite show
just by default my live one day not
either of them I've seen Chris put away
will get disgusted by the way that I eat
Malta love which is [ __ ] crazy because
they're looking at me eating Malta of
like you would look at someone taking
out an unloved of bread and just biting
off the edge of it which is totally not
what's happening
mmm at all because it's very different
that's right moist like a desert almost
as no model if you can't slice it butter
it and put it the toaster but it's just
unnecessary so I think bottom all those
fantastic it's really but it's just
adding in steps to something that
doesn't need to be made any better so
the best way to eat serene first up the
main advantage of it is it is impossible
to get that much that many carbs into
yourself that easily no other food is
that calorie dense in terms of
carbohydrates honey it's not food like
it's not easy nah it's just so easy as
long as it in so you like right Oh block
this like that cuz you just go it's no
more it's like a tortilla so you open it
up wrap it up and then you just feed it
out and then you know when you're doing
side like silicon sealant yo yo you push
from the back yeah like a breadstick
polyfill there let's take a question
from the muck you can get a gun you
could probably buy one from Wilco for
Pablo and just squeeze it yeah exactly
and then it'd take 120 grams of carbs in
a single I mean anyone who's watching
should know should be easy they should
be eating sorry right now so just on
that note obviously everyone knows about
the the magical carbfat combination that
just makes food irresistible and then
they just keep eating it so
a quant is the perfect example because
it's so unfeeling and you can just pop
out garlic to it really so think of like
I said as in like I'm talking savory
you're talking to not not to a croissant
no okay
so yes it's not Hannibal so yeah maybe
I'm less full from a fatty meal so I
think it would make sense that you add
salt to chips and you can eat more of
them and so the other thing that if you
if your rice and kind Iranian rice
you're going to like a Persian
restaurant they'd have the rights for
the butter on top and the saffron and
those it's really like becomes very
slippery rice and you can just put it
mind it like yes so those rice is quite
dry isn't it usual is natural this is
something special
the the magic that is serene I don't
think it can I don't think anyone really
is this how you thought ways through the
flavors because there are some really so
chocolate chocolate is really good
original I just leave that that's it
like that's too basic you don't need to
hang our husky buttered that's the
beginning yet if that's begin it that's
entry you don't really need to start on
that just go straight for the banana all
you want is banana don't [ __ ] about with
these like lunchbox loaves because you
get started and then you stop so you
think it's not a nothing Tyler yeah it's
and if you need to gain weight or if you
are an athlete or if you are a human
being that require sustenance by soaring
there we go
that's my life track so the this banana
is like five fruit which is very nice by
fruit there's nursin and apples apples
all Tana they did a blood orange and
chocolate chip ah that was a scream for
special thanks for Halloween I got hold
of some of that but I've got my
stockpile they've got a guy yeah okay
guy HQ and my life goal is to become
sponsored by sorry that sorry
at sorang HQ IE can instantly get that
man either grammar I've got many people
after that if I'm in here next on the
next life hack Sly Fox 106 and we're all
just wearing soaring t-shirts then a
yellow really Jason
yeah yeah bright yellow it make you look
good thanks man you look nice and young
anyway moving on what's next
let's go worn yellow list gone I don't I
have an Ireland yellow Enter Shikari
t-shirt that would nowhere near fit me
now
I saw the green Ford Russian t-shirt for
Russia moving on okay how do we talked
about micro bags
no is this a nice thing so then this is
another physical one let's move on to a
digital one cool
so working memory txt so this is a car
Newport idea of you have a permanent
capture available on your computer with
easy access at any time so I always talk
about like that most people don't have a
capture they might have some way of
sometimes capturing some things in
certain circumstances but they don't
have a universal way to just something
comes onto their into their general
inbox into the awareness and they have
to do something with it or just capture
it down and then process it into one of
their systems this allows you at least
while you're at a computer it's the
equivalent of carrying a notebook run
with you so you'll be doing a task
something comes into your head or
something happens either I need to fix
that that you don't want to be derailed
from the task that you're currently
doing
so you open working memory txt dump it
down in there get back to it use it just
like a notepad
yeah so some people use a notepad file
in it the athlete no path was in trouble
don't know there's one yeah or notes I
use because because I use Evernote for
everything else you can have a little
elephant in the top of the taskbar you
should click on and it opens up like a
unformatted bit of text you can just
dump ideas into there does it actually
add it to Evernote though you can but I
just might as well yeah why don't you
Alfred and then add it to Trello wolf
yes you can do that as well with Alfred
but by having something that like
thought I need to get I mean your first
the first everyone that we did on one
one was capture those have a capture and
it also came back up on 103 this so
because it has capture I've got a list
of stuff for capture because you need
like that's why Tobi is a capture for
like you make sense web links yeah you
you busy you're driving whatever you
just want to put it into something and
then yeah best capture so the one of my
biggest problems the capture zone I'm
driving so I'll be done driving and I'm
like I thought something
yeah so now it's just hey Siri that's
good so he's got a Tracy's how do you do
it
make a note you just say remind me to
and it okay because you only need you to
like it but you don't need like three
words of the key right and it will bring
it back yes we would share the word the
only thing is if anyone has any
suggestions because iOS 12s coming up
they've improved the voice notes
function and it syncs with mark and all
of that stuff if someone can find a way
to really quickly do a voice note swipe
up from the bottom add it to your it's
not as part maybe in the beta it's not
part of the options there so did it open
the app when you do it from there
because you can have it in your dock at
your home so you can swipe it can go out
of an open voice notes from there but
then you'd have to press and hold are
you talking about swipe up from bottom
and just press and hold yes so some way
just I know that sounds really pedantic
to minimize the number of steps to do
something but it would be nice yeah why
you should use Siri Siri never never but
you are using an iPhone 5c you get you
get but Siri improves the more you use
it that's the the hey Siri thing say
there you go she won't show up now that
it that's improved exponentially the
more abusers hundreds of times are I'm
lying there like hey Siri hey Siri and
nothing and it just hates me Arab and
your your phone gets me over in here
like by having that as it so that will
work that can be across either side of
the room and I think of something I have
toffee pallets have you seen the lexer I
don't do it so Alexa Google home and
waffle site
yeah oh sorry agree absolutely sure well
Julian was having sex with his wife and
I like to just went boom hmm that's nice
and he was like right Yeah right
John have you got one this is a book
recommendation solid yep so I listened
to on rack by recommendation of Ben if
he's listening a book called
living with a seal by a guy called Jesse
it's what I think Nautilus so this guy
is like mega successful done multiple
businesses his wife greatest
yeah so like very very successful couple
some [ __ ] good genetics in that
family oh yeah and he was like right
alright so he was at a he was at a
marathon or an ultra marathon but it was
a team ultra marathon and there was as
everyone's there on a team and there's
he describes it as this massive black
shredded guy who just did the whole
thing himself and he's like gets to the
ambien he's like limping and was
bleeding everywhere and he finds his
contact details looks him up realities
is like extremely decorated Navy SEALs
he the one that wrote the post about he
broke like for burns and his foots and
snot David gargons has oh no no no
so guesses details rings muffin says I
want to pay you to just live with me for
a month and he's like I'll do it
love David Oman's David Coggins who's
David covenants of the seal oh maybe he
doesn't reveal his name
it's David Collins he just calls him
seal it's David Collins David Goggin
yeah how do you know that because the
whole time in the book is like I'm not I
can't say his name I'm if it's not David
Goggins uh-huh then there's another guy
that's done the exact same thing right
and going to live there did he make him
jump in a frozen lake yeah yeah it's
David Goines not the author the Navy
SEAL is the name seal is David doggins
okay and the guy that you're talking
about the author is called Jesse it's
Allah Jesse it's that nicely to listen
to Joe Rogan podcast search Joe Rogan
Jesse it's Allah and you will get to
hear the behind the scenes to that book
[ __ ] me where he Said's exactly what it
was like way inception you made him jump
in me just watching Johnny butcher
Alfred what's really upsetting me why do
I butcher it
so he's um it is the equivalent of
watching your mum like type aged
because I did I did Clara lon I did
Chrome and then use Google yeah it's
just inefficient and then move the mast
over to the little arrow but it wasn't
effective I'm gonna do okay well I mean
want to get a laptop up to check it was
Jesse it's long yeah so the reason that
that's a good book yep is you realized
so the whole time the guys like getting
woken up before II am and made to run
nine miles and then he pay this man to
just yeah there because it is nearly
equal the only condition is that he has
to do everything that he tells
so he builds me up to the point of doing
a thousand push-ups in a day to making
him running in the snow it's awful
thousand pressure per se is not not that
bad actually
I mean I'm it's like every 20 minutes
you know he was all set is every hour
you do 100 I think for its foreign
wouldn't try your eyes and your are
factoring in the the keywords of fatigue
by the time you don't like 800 so I've
done the Armstrong program where I was
doing 400 a day like in the morning
before I've covered and that was if you
ever work with an wooden believable
chest yeah just did you build up you
built up to 400 a this guy's going from
scratch from its from 0 to if I was in a
day in about in a month's time okay but
anyway so the point is I think so many
people we get so many people saying like
oh I can't do that cuz I love a train or
I can't die it like that I'll be too
hungry or I know I can't wake up early
cuz it's too difficult you listen to
this and you just like follow us about
this guys getting woken up like there
was one thing he did where he made him
to you he made him go for a run every
two hours for 48 hours or something yeah
anyways including sleeper stuff yes
every weight one of every two outlets
and he like goes in to get the David
Goggins because I'm seal which I think's
brother I need you ruined if in the
opposite side it goes in goes into
sealed bedroom and he's sleeping in an
oxygen chamber but he's created in this
guy's flat why him just because got to
be ready Freddy
I was given a big one the big in about
all the like push-ups but actually
running every two hours even if this
hundred meters no way so he doesn't
remain chance get into that icy lake and
he like it turns out that the legs are a
lot colder than they expect and then he
promised to run up a mountain like you
just I start and thought about like I'm
such a little [ __ ] like this guy's just
government and maybe SEAL training for a
month it sounds like a great book I'm
gonna I'll get hold of that and a few
dad cool so that's that the take home is
like I think he says at the end um how
are we gonna back to ever know they take
the take note the take home is like your
body will adapt to pretty much whatever
you throw at it yes the hard thing is
getting be putting yourself through that
process which is why you need
accountability you I think I think
ability and someone to direct you is the
main take you are the main missing part
yep of what most people have got yeah
but for instance recently I've studied
on programming from re programming for
CrossFit as part of my rehab and I
haven't missed a single day up until now
I've always missed days of training but
I know if I miss a day of training that
it's gonna pop up on fit but to my coach
anyone's good he's gonna come on his
brand new laptop get something get
something what it's not even anywhere
near that it's just on the metal oh no
but it's not my laptop anyway right so I
am going to do swipe right on Spotify so
if you use Wi-Fi on your phone this is
unbelievable and I only found out about
it by accidentally doing it so if you
going to open up Spotify browsing
through tracks that you want to play if
you press and hold on a track and then
swipe to the right you'll add it to the
play queue Johnny's doing it on the
album art leaving me yes swipe right
swipe right to add to the queue and
what's really cool is you can start a
playlist so you can be playing through a
bunch of songs strobing left it can be
used they go so that will play next and
then it will jump back to the playlist
you're in so let's say I slowly I hate
having to interrupted yeah so let's say
that you're listening to an album Anil
at all and listen to bringing their eyes
into new album by really fancy just
having three songs from misery signals
and one from you Mia six in there
quickly jump out search swipe swipe
search again swipe again and it will
play those in order then jump back to
the playlist that you're in and say like
that is especially for training it's
like making a miniature playlist
immediately hmm and then if you've got
your saved songs you can create a little
order of them by doing it that way as
well three top
associations that's why right off I
swipe right into my family okay
to a physical one for me micro bikes I
can't remember if he did this in 103 but
these are bpa-free that bisphenol-a
which is a one of these plastics that
secretes then releases estrogen so you
don't want that so these these denry be
it's really angry and it sometimes gets
passive-aggressive in a sort of cyclical
nature so nowadays so don't you want to
avoid that these bags don't have it you
put vegetables or chicken or whatever in
could be frozen could be ruined
temperature whatever you pull off the
little sticky bit fold over put it in
the microwave and it microwaves things
to tender perfection within 2 minutes 3
minutes so you could take chicken and
because it it's a semi permeable bag so
you can put it on a plate and it fills
up with steam this inherent in the
chicken and then like pumps in and out
so it keeps it circulating cooks it
through evenly makes it really tender
and it's just the best way to cook how
much y'all get no they are like three
pounds for 200 something like that so
like I bought I bought a block of them
last year and have barely used half of
them so far and - really good - bloody
excellent that's awesome
same thing so something I do is just
like I'll put in some like a block of
frozen ginger some chicken thighs some
veg maybe a bit of spice or something
fall over put in the thing so it's okay
it's a it's a fast slow cooker yep
lovely tender chicken nice that's good
what you're the first person that told
me that you can microwave chicken it's
realizing obviously you can't microwave
chicken on the boat but yeah it's
something to do with the way the bone
reacted to the thing yeah it doesn't
cook the meat around the bone you can
only use boneless chicken when you
microwave there you go that's you've got
two for one there we go
don't microwave chicken yeah man well
actually that you can microwave chicken
but not burns three one have I mentioned
my coffee you know Arabic no so this was
like I'm stealing as well but this was
mentioned this was recommended to me by
someone else
the it's really G it was at 40 quid
which in the context of like a coffee
machine is not very much money
and it's just a drip filter coffee
machine what's the brand I think there's
like pod coffee machines like 72 oh yeah
yeah I can remember the brand I can get
a link for the show no show notes below
but basically it's a cupcake filter
which is metal match so there's no like
you don't have to get the paper filters
younger and it's got a simple Vegas but
a special name for the thing that it's
very similar thing you've got in the
office okay but just having that on a
timer for 6 a.m. is there's been a
massive shift for me it's 40 good
because I yeah and like even what does
it take ground there yeah ground
yeah so I've also bought I also bought
coffee grinder but I'm a bit of a coffee
snob like I wouldn't just how efficient
are dog I think aficionado yeah like
don't don't no I don't mind
that's the thing that's the difference
between aficionado and snob and if you
don't mind having [ __ ] coffee yeah as
long as you have some coffee yeah but
you do appreciate so when when I'm at
home and I can't make some iced coffee I
like to so put it up put the grounds in
the night before and then just I wait
I've walked downstairs and you've got
when there's a hot jerk of coffee that's
really nice that it keeps it hot and
you've refined the blend till you can
set the strength and set the obviously
the amount of water yeah the amount of
coffee I'm getting deja view about the
coffee machine and the Spotify swipe
right haven't done so the Spotify Swiper
is definitely not I've not heard
anything ok and that one wasn't he's
done he did take coffee into work to
save you money ok there's double double
can't egos huh yeah so don't worry man
okay so next up for me I've been wanting
to do this one for ages and I didn't
really know how to put it across so if
you are in this day and age and you're
still using the word gay as a colloquial
casual word that essentially means
rubbish you're just asking for trouble
and
like you will get someone somewhere is
going to find real problem with it and
rightly so because it sure you shouldn't
be using that word so I think a lot of
the time what people mean when they say
gay is lame or rubbish but what comes
out is a word which is quite fiery you
know it elicits reaction of say oh I'm
something they don't mean that gay is
rubbish that's just the word that they
go to follow so what I realized was this
is a long time ago it's like five longer
than five years ago I needed to cycle
that word completely out of my language
I didn't want to resort to it at all but
uh like when he still you know he got
[ __ ] it was just it was reactionary
for me
so what I needed to do was come up with
a solution for how I was no longer gonna
be known going to use that word and for
me it was cycling out the word gay and
using the word lame and the advantage of
using the word lame as it sounds so much
like the word that you you were using
that you it's a seamless transition
between the two and after forcing
yourself to say the word lame about for
three weeks four weeks the word gays out
of your vocabulary and you're now we've
insulated yourself from being in the
center of a big scandal so I'm gonna be
the the knob and the devil's advocate
for this verb blame some I like this is
people who are looking to be offended by
stuff but some people would conflate
lame with someone who is paralytic were
disabled and so then it's like ours it's
referring to it as that but I think the
defense is something can be lame with no
reference to that whereas if you call in
something gay that you can't fall back
on or just meant like the happy version
of gay it's not quite the same but like
the word [ __ ] idiot imbecile [ __ ] all
of those were clinical terms for someone
with subnormal IQ until they became
she's nominated yeah they just became a
standard vocabulary and then they became
a so the etymology of all of those words
medical it all medical words [ __ ] I
suppose the difference there is that
what someone's it someone's using that
to almost try and get that across their
own they're like whereas saying
something's gay that you aren't saying
that persons that's homosexual you're
just using it as a way people have
complained it that word with meaning
lame or rubbish essentially so like you
were saying you stub your toe you are
[ __ ] you don't mean like Oh feces you
you mean like it's just a bad thing
that's when PJ and P would say is the
same circuitry that's like screaming
yeah the primal squeaks if you've ever
heard someone accused someone else that
being a wimp if they've ever used the
f-word to rather not say because that's
a little bit that elicits them a little
bit more the bundle of sticks yeah right
yeah pop balls [ __ ] balls [ __ ] they
don't mean that's a bundle of pork balls
mm-hmm your report ball they don't mean
that I think what they mean is you're a
wuss you're a nancy boy you're a [ __ ] I
wonder if worsen whim
anyway my point is my point is that you
shouldn't be using the word gay to refer
to anything really and cycling it out
and using the word lame is the easiest
route from that I think you can find to
doing it and once you start doing it
lame actually sounds a lot of people
understand what you mean a lot more a
lot more effectively mm-hmm and it
sounds quite good it's nicely rounded
there are some gay people I know that
use gay as a derogatory term as well but
I think it's almost like black people
using the young ones yeah it's kind of
like a semi ironic you're allowed thing
is I know you're allowed to I'm just
real reason I'm wrong version of the
pakis I was laughing at the video from
who is America yep definitely what's
that series from you know in Isis if
they think that you are a homosexual
this is the worst thing that could
happen so you need to drop the pants and
shout America and it's on it yeah
definitely watch it if anyone who's it's
worth watching as well it's
comedy is just frightened yeah a really
social experiment under dark comic
trolling all of America isn't it
Rowan Atkinson's thing about offense
recently he's gotten a load of [ __ ]
right I don't know how much trouble he's
got in but I think it's fantastic
Anton he's basically saying like the the
culture the society is moving more and
more towards this idea that people but
like we should protect before people
from being offended and he's saying
actually the flip side like we should
people should be offended getting
offended all the time because it's the
only way to insulate yourself from it
this ninety snake cultures what the
snowflake can do community in America's
come from I don't know I'd be interested
to hear in the comments below if you is
from America do see this but to me
everything we see from America that
comes out is kind of like a sitcom I
can't tell the difference between a
seminar that got someone shouting at ben
shapiro and an episode of Arrested
Development like you know I mean it's
it's just all one the sizes Poe's law
isn't it where if you were to on the
internet if you were to try and
characterize and do is a sarcastic post
or something about that about a view and
it's taken seriously or you can't
actually characterize it enough I'm
going to find the exact it I understand
what you mean though so yeah my point is
that in America at the moment it does
seem like there's this hyper snowflake
super protectionist nanny state kind of
mm-hmm then it seems like a pirate is so
so that this was it is like without a
clear indicator of sarcasm and the
authors in the author's intent it is
impossible to create a parody of extreme
views so obviously exaggerated that it
can't be mistaken by some readers for a
sincere expression of the parodied views
mm-hmm so that's the that's the problem
when people take real-world examples to
extremes when people become offended
absolutely anything you can't take the
piss out of being offended or anything
because someone actually was well it's
impossible to parody a creationist in
such a way that someone would mistake
not for a genuine creationist article
yes fair enough so
my point is really just leading on from
what you were saying which I understand
it's like don't say this because it
offends people but it's like in the same
way that you know people in our post it
about vaccines like all that is is
exposure to something to build
resilience to them and actually like the
more you insulate yourself more
sensitive and rule you become precise
villainous okay cuz eventually will but
you will get offended by something and
then it'll be cataclysmic yeah there's
some there's some things that I think
that you shouldn't there's certain areas
that you can avoid being offensive it
quite easily specialized language is one
of them I'm not asking you to compromise
on your views I'm not asking you to
change anything about the core tenets of
who you are hmm I'm just saying the way
that you express yourself could be done
in a way which loses you nothing but
gains someone else a lot and also gave
you a lot as well yeah I think the key
thing is like you're not a huge positive
it's it's using say things that are
necessarily like it cuz all is it's just
lazy language isn't it really it's like
a filler word and then if that's gonna
offend someone it's easy [ __ ] I get to
swap it out yeah yeah and if you want to
stand a hard line on like First
Amendment then sweet but it is it's a
weird thing to take a stand on because
it's an accidental homophobic comment
you and actually like it doesn't reflect
anyone's if you use it a lot of the time
like me and if it really does and you
were true homophobe then all the power
to you cuz you being as authentic as
you're living with lemon with virtue but
you're gonna get lynched by some guy
it's not really still being used
correctly so like actually yeah it's
nothing else what we're doing here is
correcting is correcting the use of here
like if there's some homosexual
squirrels when you go that's gay right
good yeah yeah correct
stocking picked it up date to date right
come on what's like we we needed a gay
man on the podcast was I'm still
searching for one I was gonna use my
hairdresser if I wanted oh I can't if
you're a bum or a bunny uh simple
replies didn't then sure we had a
message about it I didn't someone saying
I'll come on podcast I think we maybe
had a message somebody
answer number three right next Scully is
it your turn okay so mine is digital is
not always better
and I think this is because like since
we're all so far down the life at rabbit
hole it's easy to think that like if we
get the smart light bulb and the smart
lock and all this stuff like maybe just
me like I always think oh great it's a
new development no I saw a smart lock
that was a hundred dollars to buy
clearly millions of pounds of wiser joy
Dorris it's like an American company
like on one of those start a Kickstarter
fungoides millions of pounds of research
into it and this guy is just like a
handyman did a video about it and he was
like right so I'm gonna look at this
lock it's got a fingerprint sensor here
it's got it really like special
encrypted lot mechanism and whatever he
was like right let's just turn it over
and the back
he just with like a sleeve and a little
sticky little bit of sellotape or
something he just twisted the back and
it came off and then there was a single
screw unscrewed it the battery was there
pulled out the battery and the thing
just unlocked and he's like and he's
like right so on
yes it's very secure from the front but
if anyone gets it off you can literally
just twist it off you like this wouldn't
require any equipment apart from
screwdriver and so surely for it to come
off though it's no longer on the door in
which case how is it unlocking it I said
it's like a padlock that you can I think
really like they caught the core value
of what you're talking about here is
that we always presume that newest is
best yeah and the reading guide that's
available on FS blog which is the farm
Street blog and currently addicted to
thank you very much George McGill on
that they talk about people never want
to read books that are more than ten
years old is that what the classics are
classics for a reason they've lasted
hundreds of years like it if you Marcus
Aurelius meditations have existed for
thousands of years why do you think
people still read them I'm reading that
largely
unbelieving yeah like you know that and
the same with fiction people think that
the what shinier and has the most click
baby title is always what's best mm-hmm
no there's tried and tested solutions
that's not to say like oh well horses
have been around for ages therefore we
don't need cars I wonder where the part
of us the effort thing that like you see
now that people know how to tap into our
like our top five tips to well to be
productive and yeah well I'll read that
rather than like sit and read some hard
book because it's old earnest it's more
difficult to penetrate but definitely me
I didn't enjoy I found it more difficult
to relate David Allen's getting things
done to nowadays because he's talking
about pages and filer faxes and stuff
yeah like no no I need this optimized
for Evernote and iCloud Thursday on it
oh really where is it on getting things
that they have a membership website and
in fact you know what I'm gonna way out
to apartment okay so just digits not
always better thing I got a couple of
smart lightbulbs after one of our
friends was was raving about the philips
hue is all made excellent i drive into
my house a garage door opens and the
lights come on in sequence my kettle
comes on and then like these i get
kicked out of my mattress and these
trials it i go into the trial you see
like the toaster comes up and a jamming
my dog called Gromit puts on the wrong
trousers yeah and so i got a cheap
version but no no no you've bypassed
very very quickly they're the key issue
which is that got the cheap version yes
I did but it wouldn't be any the problem
I'm gonna describe it would be no
different with any of these more
expensive ones and that is that it
renders you a light switch redundant
because all the light switch does is
activate the Wi-Fi and so if you switch
it off you've turned off the smart
function if you turn it on you then have
to go and find your phone from wherever
from whatever wherever it is in the
house scroll to the app open the app
wait for it to connect turn off the
light or turn on the light so if
anything it makes turning on or off the
light so many more steps I want you to
your room yesterday
yeah click the light yeah but you have
to turn off then on then off and on
again for it
work as a normal light so Jesus Christ
so like and same with my microwave I've
got a analog microwave you just twist
the thing and it goes Bing yeah
absolutely great like so when I'm using
the micro bugs put it in just turn it a
bit rather than having to faff around
with like defrost mode and put in the
number of minutes and it's like if you
want just the minimum number and so like
the same padlock light switch I think
this is I think this is why progress
especially technologically occurs in
large jumps and the incremental changes
that occur in between them are really
people just repackaging [ __ ] already
said about the Bluetooth saltshaker and
I don't know what what it needs it like
what function it they've done this
someone's like oh bluetooth is a thing
let's just put it in a salt shaker and
you're like isn't it's gonna be five
times the price it's gonna break and you
have to have a device to like the way
that I feel about this smart bulbs thing
and I I've seen them in the Apple shop
but you know out for a while and I've
always looked into life whoa hey what is
that solving for people because
ultimately you want a bulb to be on or
off that yeah I know the thing that's
been that's given me the most value and
I I I get so excited when it happens
every time because it's just a physical
plug timer you know the old school like
you you set the time plug it in and then
when it gets dark the lights just come
on on the road and it's like that was
like a 2-pound thing you just plug in
your eye into so someone someone may
disagree I'm gonna I can think of a
number of viewers who will disagree but
for me smart homes at the moment it just
everybody wants to have some Elon Musk
3,018 [ __ ] like glass infinitely
glass everywhere controlled like
equilibrium you seen equilibrium like it
like that that's what they want and
you're like no it's not like all that
your Alexa can do is [ __ ] save things
to your notes with misspelled words and
like add [ __ ] to a shopping cart Spotify
it's it's bollocks like the technology
is so far behind what we need one of the
things that I know Phillips who does
you can have in your room you can have
the lights hooked up to your TV and when
stuff happens on your TV I'll move the
light so let's say a cars come in order
to blue car it'll make blue go around
the room okay cool that's quite a kind
of trust in cinematic it's an epileptic
sweat dream isn't it it's nice it's not
necessary and like I think the point of
smart home is its you're removing which
should make it easier to get the
destroyer so that you know you could
link up but like you've got the nice
synthetic blanket on mmm and you just
want to have a peaceful anything the
police are outside yeah yeah any lights
of mushroom Darwin got a nest home thing
for a thermostat to psycho well you know
apparently it learns forgot the hub
careful cuz you may be I don't know I
don't know what he go he got a supporter
so you know yeah so you got you got a
thing and he was like yeah so it learns
when you're at home and it turns it up
and turns it off and it's supposed to
make it is that book because I don't
have a routine eyes life I'm getting in
the house it's [ __ ] freezing from one
I don't get it back and it's not that
and it thinks it's learning news I just
turned it off he's gotten to the stage
now where he's using what my mom and dad
use which is the switch on the front of
the boiler Wow another one that's inside
the timer is going straight to the
mainframe and oh yeah he's bypassed
everything so yes I think you like
technology isn't always bad ladies and
real I really nice as it is but yeah
like a [ __ ] selectively yeah like if
you're buying us anything smart for your
home
I think you need probably at least twice
the scrutiny if not most like have a
problem that you wanted to solve duress
think like up and the mistake that I had
with the lightbulbs there was no problem
I was trying to solve I just it's just
exciting Occam's razor
mmm so that an example is there is a
coffee machine like that's not complex
you want a coffee under monitors a
problem or it makes something that I
already do a little bit for the most
direct route between that which not like
cos so so the person who recommended you
said got all the surface been fans
watching this is all your fault
he was getting excited because an
espresso have released a Wi-Fi coffee
machine and I was like okay but what are
you gonna do what are you gonna use that
for is it so you can let's flick it on
from on your away yeah but like it's a
penny at the same
thing got Wi-Fi cattle and he's like
we'll have to fill up the cattle yeah
I'm cycling so like this still and also
like look how how how fine-tuned is
everybody's life where like the minute
that would you would take to go and
press the kettle on
so here's you can't you can't give it up
and always that idea for a lot of people
that are going to be watching who are
potentially obsessive optimizers of
which I guess we broadly fall into
categories to one degree or another you
need to look it am I am i avoiding the
hard important stuff
yeah to just tack something onto the
side like if you're sitting in bed
looking at you from for 15 minutes
before you get up on a morning like what
the [ __ ] you Wi-Fi cattle doing it
exactly exactly yeah yeah that is lame
yeah I feel that way about so it's like
people it's like when someone's
obsessing about saving money on a
purchase and then they like spend lower
quit on a night out yeah well they're
paying what do you do pounds of interest
on credit cards yeah they're like that
like you know I don't buy lattes gonna
buy Starbucks coffee it's waste of money
it's like you are looking at a tiny
piece of a puzzle that is cracking and
broken and like it's yeah I think that
as a whole massive topic we probably
should cover in an upcoming episode
because I've been thinking about it an
awful lot recent have been reflecting on
trying to do the basics just really
really well
yeah and that's where you elicit the
because downstream from the basics
there's a lot more things that go right
and if you don't use your phone in the
morning before you do your entire
morning routine you laughing the rest of
your day will go so smoothly so I think
there's a simplicity in in any field you
get to the point where it's like
actually all you need to do is this
simple thing really well really
consistently and we were speaking about
this with productivity how there's an
article from Tim Ferriss where he talks
about if all you did was work
uninterrupted for two or three hours in
the morning on the most important thing
for you to do that day the
scarcity would be like up in the top
percentiles of most productive people in
the world on the right see that you
don't need like Evernote and anything
that you need a list of things look at
it go
what's the most important I'm gonna do
it I'm going to do just that for three
hours and it but like people don't do
that because doing the most
uncomfortable thing is often like
intimidating difficult like we
procrastinate on it we don't want to do
it and there's that thing in in
everything like well we believe that the
object that we're going to purchase is
going to be the answer to our questions
yeah like it's the exact same reason as
to why people believe in fat burning
tablets or why this next die it's gonna
be the next thing you like no you just
really could do with doing some exercise
how often you training a week oh well
I've gotten to do a morning walk on
Sunday and you're like okay why the [ __ ]
you bothered about a fat-burning tablet
when you're not training like yeah and
the same thing with I I fall prey to all
the time like the other day I was going
to buy a new meditation cushion right oh
no that one okay not one hundred and
twenty quid I have it's a roadie how I
was gonna get a new meditation cushion
I'm like you don't need a new meditation
cuz it's not going to help you meditate
and the other one that we're referring
to is like a hundred and thirty dollars
Cole can you work to come I can't
remember but it's like a it's a vegan
friendly non-gmo Paleo gluten-free
really clever because I've got a really
nice like sales page and it's just
review at that point just on the floor
yeah if you're not worried about that's
what I was like I can just sit on the
floor I have a floor yeah I don't need
any other floor wherever you go there's
always a always very mental impact of
making any unless you're efficient is
there a fish you could do with that
cushion if you're a fish yes he's still
technically a floor but you might not be
able to down there yes unless those
regular make your ears pop there's those
little things that the ball the white
ball and the big teeth yeah yeah so very
interested if anyone's watching and that
thinking like use if you're just not
using smart light system correctly so I
just looked up on the philip ii website
because I thought like I wonder whether
the syllabus you have thought about it
but it it says your your main light
switch is written
really so think that they're bringing
out Smart Switches okay
I mean if ya like I'd like to do some
replacing that's which is which the
irony goes beyond what I think we're
able to discuss really how that goes
like when when it's like let's make a
smart like [ __ ]
let's make switches we can put on the
wall smart so yes there is there I think
there is something where you can get
paint that you just touch the wall and
it turns a light on now that I think's
fantastic she could turn the light on
self anyway like it does that's how I
really were solving a problem the
problem is getting up and turning the
light one off so I imagine the paint is
three times as expensive you still have
to get three well yeah yeah of course
and like the whole thing but usually
they're almost like the Phillips he was
trying to solve which is it it's
difficult inconvenient sometimes
difference there is that there's someone
for whom that cost is going to be
insignificant and then that's okay
whereas for no one the inconvenience is
acceptable of the light switch not
working
yeah carry on Johnny Europe you got one
yes I do it's all on the same in the
same vein it's another book
recommendation and it is happy by Darren
brown this is the one where Reese lights
the secret by Rhonda burnin mmm-hmm it's
later wash it it's late a lot of it is
what we speak about on this podcast and
I listen to it on a plane I'm on the way
to one of many weddings that I've been
to that's the reason Johnny hasn't been
on the probably stucking wedding I just
love a good wedding so I just been going
them can you do a wedding hugs
well you probably yeah I didn't use so
not on purpose I was actually really
grateful for the way that they were but
but anyway yeah so I remember I got on
the planes five-hour flight to Cyprus
listening Darren Brown's book on tea
time speed go on the plane like still
you know the golf up his productivity
focus got off the plane thinking I'm not
sure there's any point honestly can you
give me the opposite so he he speaks a
lot about he uses concept borrows
concepts from a lot of people I was a
lot of Concepcion was stoic so stoicism
borrows some concepts from like thinking
fast
slow predictably irrational but
basically that we are always just
constructing a reality to try and create
happiness but happiness is never
something that will arrive at and it's
it's all it's more about the experience
in the process so he rubbishes a lot of
goal-setting and stuff that I remember
starting him started going into thinking
I feel like from the amount of reading
I've done on this I've got a pretty
well-formed opinion I was like you know
what he's right like it's just the
urgent host:you because he is clearly a
for anyone who follows Aaron Brown and
he's clearly a very intelligent man he
was taken the concept of happiness and
thought I'm gonna really dig another
steamroller and he's gone and just don't
got lots of of concepts from most
different places and I think really it
comes back to he talks about how you can
be convinced to believe anything which
is that the crow so does or all of it
boy guess who's like I've convinced
people to believe that they've been
zombie apocalypse
exactly so with that you can also be
convinced that you are or aren't happy
by a series of stories or thoughts you
believe and the goal-setting or chasing
something you're convincing yourself
during that process that you will be
happy when it happens but you never are
so I read the book if you've got audible
that's how I was listen to it it sounds
like it sounds obviously haven't read it
but it sounds a lot to me like the
argument to hit on a cavitation which is
this object is going to give me
fulfillment you what we are doing with
the goal setting is just replacing or
the object with the goal yeah however
the difference that I think there is
that when you break goals down into
targets their daily targets you get a
different sense of fulfillment from
overcoming an obstacle definitely yeah
like you don't get a sense of
fulfillment from saving 10 pounds
towards the car mmm-hmm but the steps
are more granular feeling like you're
moving feeling like you're making
progress move over overcoming and having
adversity and getting past it I think is
a core tenant of what makes human life
quite this is why that a guy called Tim
herb and he writes a blog called wait
but why which is
so fantastic he talks about happiness as
being like like nailing a Tuesday and
like not that I think most people live
their lives in a way of like I will be
happy in highly happy on Friday and I
are only happy when I'm on holiday I
will be happy when I've had a promotion
rather than like today wasn't meant and
like tomorrow is going to be part as
well that one that was one of the names
for this podcast before I did it was
gonna be called crushing your Tuesday
they're crushing a Tuesday or do I have
to go and get likes no names and well if
anyone's know the reason for that they
can send us a message we can do a full
podcast on why we need to go and get
lakhs I always do so yeah read our ad
copy and check out wait but why fighting
there but that's artistic I'm gonna do a
couple we haven't done Dropbox we
haven't done Dropbox so if you don't
know what Dropbox is it is a cloud-based
file storage system and there's a number
of ways that you can do that Apple have
got one built in Amazon even have once I
opened up a Kindle Fire AWS do you mean
is it having some Web Services is all it
is well so AWS is like the hope of the
beast of like I I didn't realize it that
hey let's not talk about this to come
here it's like the veins of the world
most most things that you interact with
there's a file it's probably on AWS
bloody hell okay so Jeff Bezos in this
end of it all anyway Dropbox is a cloud
like cloud-based file hosting service
but the difference is that if you've got
it on it do they have them what I mean
courage convinced with Dropbox and the
other two we're on one of the previous
it's not if there's anyone who listens
ardently to the
I've got them written down you will you
got all the ones that hasn't been in
that was that any as soon as we move
onto this screen Yousef will have I like
on to a laptop there'll be a very good
reason why you said doesn't
anything yeah and so I know youth
drop-off you want to like using a laptop
we're in for wearing your domain enjoy
domain as well that's into your like
this there's one of those optimized
pieces of technology I've ever seen in
my life
and like I know you don't pay for
Dropbox basically I don't pay for
Dropbox yeah I be you you know the code
I feel like I should probably sit and
learn how to do it cuz it would help
optimize things a lot but you still get
a lot out of like the user interface
that I provide I see yeah you you're
absolutely what nothing I'm just
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you are very good reason for it which is
because you have a system that's very
easy most people most people don't have
a system that is efficient as yours I
see the reason of another reason that
Dropbox is do it whether he's doing a
webinar on laptop what was it Alfred
just please just allow for it because I
think that the optimizations a whole
other that's volumes if that's tomes
isn't it but it's a lot sir at the
University curriculum that's degree so
the reason you need Dropbox mostly is
not because the fact that it's able to
host files online it's the integration
and how seamless it is so if you
download the app for your Mac you have
all I'm gonna guess there's an
equivalent on Windows if you're on
Windows
get off get off you are this is not for
you Dropbox for Mac makes all of your
files inhabit a native folder on finder
so you can browse them as if they're
files on your computer which they are
but then the app on your phone also does
the same thing so it's much more natural
way of browsing through your files what
you grinning about
[Laughter]
a lot like have you ever seen in
volleyball what's this thing before the
spike you know like the husband bilayer
it's yeah layup yes sir I've just done
this and you're using any running over
so I I was ready to pay I had about
fifty to eighty pounds a month for
Dropbox when they've launched Dropbox
infinity whether we're going to yep and
then they redacted it because it mustn't
have fit with the like file architecture
of if Dropbox would bring out infinity
and it what's up would bring out what's
up business for iOS I'll make him the
happiest man and probably the poorest
man there's to me just go for the cheese
so the Infiniti gonna see is the same as
what Chris is describing but it's
everything yeah your entire to your
laptop it's it's the the key things that
you need so for instance all the audio
files I have as soon as I bounce them
down and I master them I put them in one
master master put them in one folder
video guide Dean has got access to that
and we don't even I don't even need to
email it everything's put on there if
you want to sign up to Dropbox there
will be a link in short below you'll get
five hundred megabytes of extra space as
well I thank you very much because I
need it but you should you should
download it and you should have a crack
download the app the app for iOS is
really slick you can browse through
things and you don't have to save stuff
can preview files preview video preview
sound it's good it's good for you you
can so like so I do pay for drop up to
keep it for drugs Chris no no I get
terabyte of storage for pay puns month
and I think that's pretty good but I
think you were gonna sell Chris on that
soon and then you're both believe me
yeah until you get it but you don't we
don't need it like you probably have
four instances a month where it's like
if you had Dropbox I make it easier and
you would I'll use I'll be terrible with
it like I'll be under utilizing it
I see that you would you would you would
set up a little like an ecosystem and it
was a lovely let me give you a really
good example of how we use it for our
business right so we have all of our
artwork that all of the managers need
and the best of the album's from each
week and they get updated so I will put
the artwork in the guy that's doing the
vetting the album from the night before
will
good photos in there as well and all of
the managers have got access to on the
phone so when they need to do a social
media post all they do is just go in and
everything is as current as it needs to
be I've put the most recent of artwork
in no one ever needs to ask or why's
that
where's the flyer for last for this week
no one ever needs to ask oh I need a
photo for this new Instagram post should
in the so the guys that do social get
fed from the back end from the guys that
are doing the post sale service and I
get the artwork that comes in from the
designer and yet it's bring any
collaboration with big files but we we
do all of our podcast with with Dropbox
it shits all over we transfer and stuff
like that yes folks using we transfer is
just a big email yeah it's a big email
like it's good for one feels nervous
yeah yeah what that tell me give you
need to shift like a two gigabyte a 10
gigabyte file or something yeah fine
Dropbox is also fast though faster than
King right if you want to put a video
somewhere there's somewhere else can get
it like it's the [ __ ] underneath my
dresses yeah did I mean it without the
link no one else can get it mmm
unbelievable so I use box sync as well
which gives you 50 gig free Yemen Yemen
Yemen it's the same Dropbox but yeah
gives you 50 get free but is it my
service on Gaza Strip and service you
guys just don't trust so that's
something that's and we were looking at
installing a bot like a support function
on my website at the day and this is it
the skill use of ours is like I I would
just pay for the most expensive thing
yeah like I just see what does everyone
else whatever else using let's just pay
for that and she said well always find
like a cheaper of them about that any
trait probably know exactly that it's
not do you remember when Ben Harrison
was thinking about getting a pair of air
pods and so thinking about getting a
pair of airports and you replied try
mine
and Johnny said well he bought pair of a
pods
I was I was panicking at tears and you
are new and you I thought you thought
airports and you've not told me and you
went no don't worry I haven't you bought
some five-pound
Bluetooth ones that don't work can't
connect no battery life see that this is
all fabrication they work they
a little dental floss container odd with
me as well this is mr. Chris and I get
value get increased value beyond the
value of the thing from it being the
thing because it looks like your tampon
from it from it being the someone
commented on one of my videos saying why
do you have two pens in his ears it does
look like an oral-b toothbrush head so
like I I definitely get value from like
knowing that I've got the Apple version
like but I think you get more value from
it being a deal from a being good value
possibly I also I just didn't have a
hundred fifty pounds to spend look like
a headphone I thought like but if you
did but did you enjoy it I would yeah
like I mean that's about as big of an
accolade as you can give anything that
we so ever like there's a lot of things
that if I had the money I would do I
think the principle that used to operate
in there was good what does it do
can I achieve the same thing for less
yeah and you would get a lot more value
from that and I think that's your your
skill is finding that thing that most
people don't and like if it's 10%
cheaper I'll just go for the upper one
but this was 15 pound step and
convenience convenience and expediting
whatever the processes I think is where
me and you come in mmm where and that's
our our core satisfaction comes from
this process being as effective and as
efficient as possible yeah whereas yours
is as discounted as possible I'm
definitely though like I'm basic [ __ ]
when it comes to like so like you have
the best bank account like even stuff
like Alfred is the result of you
searching and searching and searching
for a solution and finding something I
waste a lot of time searching but you
get the gems don't I got the gems not I
hope that like collectively we share the
gems to you guys because the point is oh
[ __ ] yeah crowdsource your personal
growth
can we tip you've done one you just and
drove up just don't don't drop ups done
the Dropbox
can I piggyback off your focus matrix oh
yeah
because you see you gotta hustle on I
already had the top already had the
throne oh the Johnny called me I was I
was gonna suggest this up that and
Johnny called me up yesterday was like I
didn't realize but I actually have the
premium version already with the bundle
for the other one which think so that
the bundles
comes with the pro res that'd be why I
got it so I've really liked pompadour up
which is Queen V focus prone focus Pro
which is brilliant and this it's the
same company so they made us think even
a Pomodoro's as well we talked to him in
them I went through Pomodoro's at length
with dr. yu and Lawson he wrote the
entire he wrote his entire contribution
to the book the healthy writer on
Pomodoro's went back and looked at a
hundred and twenty Pollan maybe twenty a
hundred and twenty Pomodoro's and was
able to track exactly what you've done
on eat you are and he does the 20-20-20
rule which is every 20 minutes all its
25 on the Pomodoro every 25 minutes he'd
stand up look at something that's 20
feet away for 20 seconds to reset your
ocular nerve and your ocular muscles
because it helps you refocus on things
which reduces tension headaches and a
whole bunch of others so they haven't
listened to it it's an absolute ballot
dr. Ewen Lawson I recommend the Pomodoro
book to you tonight yeah ice cream your
value whatever is an illustrated guide
yeah it's on my kindle see he recommends
like basically 25 minutes of work
followed by five minutes of like as
close to sleep state as you can get yeah
so what I'm doing at home I just do mini
meditation between that's I think about
trying like absolutely turn off because
the theory is the harder you rest the
more you can keep going with the produce
work makes so much sense of ice bloody
cool I'm gonna write down 20 20 20 and
because also think how much meditation
you would accrue across a day
true it's only five minutes and a lot
but if you're doing ten Pomodoro's
you've so many who's doing its head and
Pomodoro's me like depot in this minute
no no it is not in a street but you do
like four and then a longer break and
then forward there maybe to the end of
the day something like that okay that's
an incredible tip so there's two
articles that I've read recently which
both people who used to be like
workaholics
so 4050 hour work weeks and then just
were like right I'm just going to do a
pompadour as a day and they got more
work done through of each through
privatization yes but they're really
cool but so Youssef recommended focus
matrix to me which is made by the same
people which is built on the Eisenhower
matrix so the idea of you have things
that are urgent and things that are
and things that are neither and you have
a quadrant that you can set up of things
that intersect so urgent aren't
important
prioritize do right away urgent and not
important you delegate so if you can
really what is it like this is the ideal
I should to hand over to someone
delegate it what if I was sorry urgent
and not important urgent and not
important important but not urgent shed
you the house and make sure you do that
stuff because that quadrant even though
it's not urgent the important but not
urgent stuff is the thing which will
grow you as a person boom you never get
around to doing because he too busy
fighting fires and then not important
not would not not important not urgent
just dismiss suck it off if you come and
you feel like a dick for even you know
how's this helping your productivity I
think it's so there's an app that just
yeah does that so I didn't realize it
has a capture feature built into this
ISA rocked my little world the other day
he told me it did as an inbox but just
suggest I think it allows you or what I
what I found from it I just use it for
two days but like immediately you feel
like I have to put this item something
one of these four which is it and you
have to justify to yourself like why is
it important of flowers in reflects on
foster you reflect on the tasks I think
it gives a bit of a gap between just or
lighting there mindfulness should I
actually be doing this because I think
that's the most important question it's
exactly what both of us need as well
yeah because I we were saying yesterday
like I no longer procrastinate but it's
not which is a massive statement he said
the tea times I've hit him said I just
says it but like I no longer do any
procrastination that's like the time
when he went in sat on a rock and
eliminated envy from his life 16 1999
yeah was it jealousy
envy similarly a lot to go into it at
the time eliminated envy from your life
sat on a rock it was I think it was we
was ready to go it was just the LA final
two hours and used for their rights very
much sorry he was doing but you know was
it across no no longer procrastinate
thinking that like oh that's the
solution to all my problems but I I
still my output and everything is still
lower than it should be because I can't
prioritize and so this up is been or not
some of the outfits that it's just as I
was like taking the space to say does
this need to be done now and actually
just doing that one thing for a long
time rather than switching between
because the the problem that Johnny and
I have it I'm sure
you definitely have is you wake up and
you're just bombarded by requests and
stuff to do in you and so anything that
comes up just jumps to the top of the
list and you try and do that for a bit
and stave off that fire and as a result
there's so much time and focus lost in
switching tasks yeah the doctor you and
Austin on the podcast said multitasking
is for Muppets yeah but there's
absolutely no evidence no research to
show that we can multitask can you tell
me about it but deep worthy work is the
Bible for this stuff like just sink your
teeth into what is the most important
thing to do oh the most urgent and
important thing to do it's the
incredible book what yeah it is I think
just remembering that it makes you feel
like a dick it it all this stuff this
for me but you can only ever do one
thing right now it's not like if you
feel overwhelmed like great it's a long
list of stuff to do something big and
talks about in his book Marburg on spur
quick oh well it's not a thing exists
but can you find all her well anyway I I
can't see anyone I well it's all in your
mind that's not worry you said best
Martin Burke on depression
he's like some people say I've got so
much washing to do tomorrow it's like no
you don't there is a large pile of
washing like it's a different thing yes
and like someone saying I'm so busy on
business I'm so overwhelmed but no
there's a list of stuff there's a long
list of stuff like you don't have to
identify with the list you just do is a
scientist a like rate of output is lower
than rate isn't coming
that's gonna happen George George McGill
who will be listening is choosing in his
pants at the moment with the Red Queen
effect which I sent to you guys
yesterday so in Alice in Wonderland
she's talking to the Red Queen and
they're running away from something I
think and the Red Queen turns to her and
saves you see now you have to run as
fast as you can just to stay in the same
place
and that is the absolute epitome of
informational overload without any
effective work being done yeah
so if anyone's interested in like I mean
VA is Virtual Assistants and stuff is
yours very much nor domain but like if
you're in if you feel like you're doing
more than you can looking at
re Meisels book called less doing so
here's a guy who's diagnosed with
Crohn's disease you recommended the
podcast today yeah yeah so he had
Crohn's disease and was only able to
work in our days that me his book it was
yes so like just outsourced his life
Denis easy and he's just very big it's a
good simple stuff that it's like it's
the kind of thing you read any like ah
obviously boom why didn't I
and it's just right out really clear
process notes for things that you don't
need to be doing isn't building a manual
of you he calls it so I mean we actually
I actually wrote before I won another
island I wrote a word document that was
how to be Chris doc okay there go you
you know just like I don't need to I
didn't mean I still don't need to be
there okay just give I could just give
it to anyone and just be like that's
what I do
that's my week that's why I do
everything yeah okay like the worst
problem about you is that it's gotten a
lot of the time it's got to be you that
does the thing like I can't have I
couldn't tell someone else what it is I
say on the front door of a club and then
get them to turn up so the manager would
go do you I'm Chris for a night no I
suppose if you you don't have to do
everything else laid off the one thing
you have to do yeah video it's it's
tough so I'm gonna do one because video
guy Dean is in the optimal position I'm
gonna do one which I use on on nights
out which is
specific kind of handshake when I really
really don't want anyone to come close
to me so Johnny you can imagine if you
can imagine that you are a drunk
customer on a nighttime you have to
stand up so if you can imagine you're a
drug customer you're gonna [ __ ] Road
drug customer on a night out okay and
you're coming up to me and you're being
[Laughter]
you know as you as you shake hands with
someone as opposed to allowing them to
fold in towards you if they go for the
hook what you do is you keep your arm
extended and push their on into their
own chest so yeah you just you push back
like that and then all that they do is
they end up with this kind of chicken
wing thing that side but you've got
complete control of where they are cuz
they're basically they're anchored from
the middle of their chest into your hand
mmm okay and for mitigating how close
the drum could get Steve it's unbeatable
I'm also going to do because I'm on the
topic I'm going to do the most effective
way to move through a crowd with people
in a nightclub Lading waving is that
being an angle angular yeah you want to
be probably you want to be more forward
than you are to the side you don't to be
at 45 degrees you want to be probably
more at 30 and then you want to go with
your non-dominant hand first and if you
have a drink you want your drink to be
held from the top of the glass what are
you doing with your arms so first times
going either out like that you can
either have a hand out if you really
need to side through a crowd of people
or you usually okay with shoulder
problem with that you don't want to be
like groping someone and then you get a
usually okay like to go like that but
you know if you go side on with
non-dominant hand first and then drink
is held from the top because that's the
most effective way to not spill if
someone knocks into you it your hand
naturally allows the way to those of the
water other
the liquid that's in there to slosh
around but it doesn't come out as if
you're holding it like that's the exact
opposite so blading non-dominant hand
and non-dominant arm first and you want
to be moving as quickly as possible
through that if you move with purpose
people get out your [ __ ] way home
like that's as advice from someone who
spends his evenings moving through
crowds of people
that's the those are two very optimal
strategies
it's a very well informed tip having
done hundreds of tiny years of
experience I had a friend at school who
always looked like he's much taller than
everyone else like always looked older
you said like dress pretty smart so like
he would come on nights out and he's
wearing like sort of like chinos and a
shirt something like that so he always
you look at me think like could be he's
an official could be fairly fairly
important and usually go up to groups of
people and go I'm really sorry I'm the
manager here with his bits of glass and
the drinks so I'm gonna have to take it
one string of them and he used to just
take everyone's drinks and walk over to
our table and put them down pezzi drinks
and normal never said anything to you
tells you to join likes it different
places yeah you do anything that
something alert and so we've got an
upcoming video that we'll do might be a
podcast it might be one long video it
might be a combination of the two which
is going to be how to beat nightclubs
hmm and this this is gonna be so good
because all the things that I would have
fallen for back in the day as a club
promoter but basically how to get into
any club for free how I get in a VIP the
booking procedure of what you need to do
and say in advance what you should say
on the door at the number of times in
Vegas the number of times I managed to
get onto Chris Brown's table by just
being commanding and saying let's so one
of the guys said to me like essentially
sorry pal you can't come in here so
sorry ma'am at work straight through
immediately like you said sorry I'm at
work sorry ma'am I work like it with a
kind of a little bit of do not me who I
am in yeah that's ridiculous of being in
a queue at Vegas was poor white trousers
pull yeah so Chris Rose Portman was
standing which we like we saw the size
of the queue
we're like I'm a bollocks wedding and
that will go speak
answer massive massive man what was like
is there any way to Schipperke even the
guy went it's Vegas you can do whatever
you want who's like how much is it he
was like how much do you think it is
important is it 200 pounds because if
it's two neurons that's [ __ ] Paul
John it take yourself off to the
collimator once you but now you guys
over there let me know who wins and then
if you do yeah sorry man I remember
being amazed at how they're like I don't
know I'll be using the wrong terms
they're like the organizer yep they're
like the guy who's like promoting the
event yep the promoter the promoter is
just going along the line of people and
people are just handing him ones a couch
and I watched him take the wad of cash
out count it give it back to him and
then give him another one like all right
no you must be just that that one you've
already covered your whatever whatever
costs you have that's your income was
like I need to move to Vegas people's
people's desires or people's own
preparedness to spend money
daran once sold to huge untick 'it's two
people who'd already bought tickets so
they paid for tickets to a New Year's
Eve party this is years ago a Riverside
and they didn't want to wait in the
queue running the queues moving like
quick if you don't have to take money
off someone outside of a nightclub and
they're just you just that the movie
like you literally just get your tickets
out scan it stop mmm-hmm you don't
usually don't need to get your ID out
either because your IDs been verified
through the purchase and two guys from
London didn't want to wait in the queue
and paid aren't fifty pounds each on top
of ten pounds each ticket entry one
hundred and twenty pounds for two
entries per visit there's this feeling
on my hours know that people like people
get sucked into this idea that like I
need to spend money to show off which is
why I like you know that when someone
buys a bottle great people yeah toss it
but like the fact it's innovation
or coming out the shows we spar on a
Friday
candy-pants right like that's the whole
point you can spend 65 pounds or a
hundred pounds on a mid-level
high level bottle of vodka and have the
entire rooms music change and a bunch of
pretty girls put on fluffy animal heads
and carry boards up they've got your
name up
it's the just pure peacocking and like
what kind of they don't spend 60 quid
I'll tell you what anyone who can do
that Conde yeah so they can both what's
really cool is when you say oh cool
what's really interesting in a nightclub
is when you see two competing groups of
males that have got a high amount of
disposable cash and they just styled
smelly oh yeah and that's it that's when
you see the cook because we don't take
the money right like it's fun for us to
watch but I'm like none of like those 10
bottles of ace of spades are 3 grand
that 3 grand none of that's going in my
pocket but you see apparently I've heard
some stories of mobs where this has gone
through the roof
and you've got two competing big groups
of guys and one will get 5 grand show 7
grand show 10 grand show and it's like a
game of chicken I've liked all right ok
yeah you think you've got that much
money no no like bigger bigger bigger
what's the largest what's the largest
bottle of vodka that you've got what's
the biggest bottle of champagne what's
the most expensive show and you just
have these two so I've taken my drink
your thing cuz they they don't go
initially for the the top one so I can
yeah which is ridiculous like it's it's
like oh ok I need to go a bit more as
opposed to just like what is wrong have
a nice time move ways someone spends 500
now what yeah what if he does have in 5
min baby there'll be something that they
just can't cater for it's like I want to
spend 5 from the ground so I'm sorry we
don't ever got anything for you like
apart from just it's scared involves
desire opens wanna see like I'm gonna
stock one bottle of really good stuff
just in case so here's here's the thing
with that so they get
anymore shut up Alice dr. palace had a
like a five liter bottle of ace of
spades I think which is I want to say 20
grand Jesus but the problem is you've
got 20 grand of your business tied up in
one [ __ ] bottle like that's 20 grand
of money tied up in that just in case so
then it comes to I knew I'd need to sell
it just a piece I was in liquidity the
liquidity this month's a little bit
tight you're eyeing up this [ __ ] 20
grand liabilities it's just sad though
because you can't even like sell it in a
rush either it's gonna be like oh so it
will sell for 80 my so you could
probably go selling it at all isn't it
like went it went in really yeah wanted
me and someone did it to 457 or
something no I don't think he paid for
any of his drinks when he was there he
believed the $0.50 being except opposed
and didn't pay for his drinks free
drinks I don't even drink i were really
consistent serious enough about that you
could get to the point of being a rapper
beads it would all be facetious
obviously 30 if you just Alfred your way
to being a rapper if you like right okay
this is single month goal do it do an
impact map just do just go all the way
to rapper get coaching I'll sort of get
coaching I'll sort see Larry
lyric-writing why divorce on I'll send
find a cause to like get a haircut and
all that so you still have to be putting
out daily videos with me have to get my
video man name of you rapping yeah yo
get Dean to to help so go beyond the
mind
screw him I'm gonna put I'm gonna throw
another one in here because we're
talking about nights out and this one
kind of jumps in with the right amount
so um when you're on a night out and
you're drunk but you can't work out how
drunk you are it's very difficult like
you think oh how much have I had to
drink
I feel quite wrecked but reflectively in
that moment it's actually quite hard so
the best approach for that is try and
work out if you can remember things that
have happened recently in the night
and then eventually you get really good
at improving your memory while you drunk
no no a very concerted mechanism yeah
that's not that's not happens in my
experience if you try and remember what
half what recently happens when you're
drunk and you can't remember it what
that means is you're probably not going
to reboot be able to remember what's
happening right now and if you know that
that level of memory loss it weighs two
too much alcohols behind it so not
having a good time if you can't remember
it then what's the point yeah that GoPro
there you go there's a bit of a
philosophical point that if you can't
remember having a good time it was a
still a good time so if Darren brown
talks gonna remember itself an
experience I don't have to read the book
I was got the toilet you wanna go to the
toilet I always go to the toilet when
I'm thinking like how much I've had to
drink
if you go to the toilet that's quiet
there's been you trying to but I think
in a pool of wheat there's a there's a
moment of like we know right that's it
that's a good point because that's like
that's like base base camp yeah like I'm
waiting before we plenty of times before
yeah so I know how they should feel by
myself has no loud music like there's
someone trying to offer me up for
shaving but nobody said not too much
esteem but I said it's a fairly quiet
time I'm like what's your in a petri
dish onions just to read see why they
cook let's see what the culture had
mmm-hmm I hate nightclub toilets he's
standing in me Lexi and inch layer of we
is the guy pressuring you to buy stuff
and he's like you're like look I am NOT
lovely if I don't want to what I know
that's nice that's my decision
well like wash your hands and they're
they hand you a towel and you're like no
no I'll get my own towel kiss
we've still never been on a proper my oh
yeah I think when you say two years ago
we were gonna do it I did we've done a
few but they we haven't gone like there
was a time we went to that it's the only
time I've ever beat at that Club they
live usually and you drunk the really
strong reigneth use 80% over for a funny
and then you had whiskey and honey with
so Chris was like you want a drink you
said I'll just have water things like
right pick a drink around picking you
one
no no really and he turned around with a
double shot of this 80% room and then a
double Jack Daniels and Coke afterwards
and he you drink the room and it just
hits you like oh no I've got a cycle
back now nicely
tell me when you go in as I'm gonna have
to take it was you sipped it that's what
I remember really clearly about that is
is like like I've seen I've seen people
drink that and be immediately sick then
you just went mmm yeah yeah it's quite
strong yeah yeah it's quite a bit we've
just ruined our palates with years of
horrible supplements and Magnon
hydrolyzed casein so my life hack is so
here are the keyboard shortcuts for
YouTube if you're watching this on nice
honestly so return to the start 0 skip
through 10 20 30 % 1 2 3 4 5 etc so the
number keys double speed or half speed
is shift and the greater than or less
than symbol and you can keep tapping
them to go all the way up to 2 times
speed all the way down to no point two
five speed K is pause J is bass face is
also pops spaces also pause space
sometimes jumps Joss you Tanya K's more
reliable at least Jamie moves back 10
seconds L moves forward 10 seconds and
with those you're just a keyboard wizard
the reason I'm so obsessed with keyboard
shortcuts is that they minimize being a
Packard Bell and having to like move the
mouse do my writing basically well so
it's why we were talking about like the
trackpad speed and moving it up to the
mark surgeon if you've not done that you
may have a slight back what I want like
immediately now go to the top corner
over you macbook because you're using a
MacBook because you are a sane human and
press on the Apple system preferences
trackpad and move your trackpad speed up
at least all the way to the max no you
will overshoot
you it's diminishing return a nut sorry
diminishing returns it's a very very
short period of not being able to click
on anything so yeah so experience the
trial by fire
to the max deal with a day of discomfort
and then suddenly realized that everyone
when you climb it but when you
acclimatize when you go back to using
someone else's laptop
it feels pedestrian you're like it's
ridiculous yeah you having to like
church shouldn't take more than one to
get to a corner to corner maybe a half
the track I think if it should give it
someone's going then you tripods what is
going on but so I I recently in fact two
days ago went through and set loads of
Alfred snippets and set up a lot of
Alfred very excited I'd a moment where I
was like you know work it doing yeah
he's right I can remember what I was
doing but I was typing something I was
like that that's the fourth time I've
written that today
well like trying to find the link in
your life yeah yeah it's so yeah you
know what it was was trying to find a
login for clients piece of software yeah
and I I know that I saw I saved it to
Evernote and I was like why I saved it
to Evernote so that can go back to ever
know again yeah to copy it again to so
sorry I mean once you even even once
you've copied it once if it's a short
period of time you don't need to make a
saving because it's a nickel it was
money with audio it's in the last 200
things that you've copied done which it
it almost it means I want you to finish
Oh an infinity copy oh really
I want you Finity copy I think that's
gonna back up a little yeah it's fine
code base the Infinity probably pull
they do you need infinity or could you
just go a thousand yeah boy if any copy
will just be snippets wouldn't know
almost like if you know what you're
searching for
would you tough you from feminie cotton
good point they just leave it you do
mean in infinite cutting or to clipboard
yeah entries there's not a thing called
affinity copy okay oh my god Anita right
I'm gonna do another one because oh
thank you sorry um I don't think we've
done much on sleeping can we do one on
your top please video guy Dean could you
just move in on no on Johnny's hair
please if that's okay I don't like it a
little bit closer I don't know thank you
yeah battery once it looks great look at
the camera please join me there you go I
think you look fantastic
the problem is you haven't got rid of
the sight that's not mine it's a it's a
it's a key commitment in it all I know I
have no involvement in it at all
they had my hairdresser has so this was
something we were learning today about
outsourcing yeah that when you're
outsourcing to someone who's an expert
don't interfere with that process
yeah like tellings deed as you meant
like Deena's [ __ ] off yeah you want you
to know if some of what you say is the
desired effect the desired outcome and
then get out the way
[ __ ] the [ __ ] off so I said I want to
talk not which was like don't leave it
to believe it but she gave me a grace
period which I'm now way out of them oh
dude there was a body there was a 14-day
killing off the very room in which under
consumer law you could have stopped the
process yeah that by now we would've
yeah very interesting that you say we
have too much stuff on sleep because the
podcast which is coming out in two days
time which will probably be about three
weeks ago when this gets broadcast is
with dr. Greger Potter
from the University of Leeds PhD in
sleep and karana nutrition he is one of
the UK's leading sleep researchers and
we did two hours on sleeping optimizing
sleep it's like the you know it's like
the supplementary information to Matthew
Walker's book we obviously I think my
tip is not necessarily because I think
where there's lots of people now with
tips on like set a fixed wake-up time
make sure your rooms Dark Horse or [ __ ]
and like lying for in an ideal world
yeah like you you sleeps just this the
seamless integrated algorithmic
existence but most people it's not it's
a bit of a mess but there are so many
people that I know who complain of like
you wake up and you're like yeah bed
like you were a sore back sore neck I've
slept on my shoulder funny I are my arms
numb and then they get back off yours in
a second
I hope you have to piggyback with it and
if I opened up thoughts of optimization
so that and then those people get out of
it and then they go try and squat or
lift weights and you're like is this
table what do you do this what dad's
pretty good actually
is he yeah it was actually Gemma who I
was speaking to in truth like she showed
me then show me the way that she lay in
bed and she was sleeping I was like do
you not wake up and feel enough locked I
was like I was on the front it's like
this I know it's like freefall skydiver
okay so there are three radios that but
for its kind of is always free-falling
listening shi-it BASE jumper they don't
they three videos by Kelly Starrett and
what that yeah they talk about rolling
up a towel and sliding it in the
pillowcase so you have pillow towel roll
towel roll sits here supports your neck
and then the pillow supports your head
so that basically if you imagine that
you're like that in bed so complete
alignment midline shoulder is back not
down like most people sleep and you wake
up and you're like ah my life isn't my
ex isn't here anymore so I started doing
that since you recommended it without
the towel I didn't know about the tie
was keep is it cuz I've got it I've got
an IKEA pillow awesome
okay hair change okay that's interesting
but it's lovely book you I think God
today I think what's key to do with
sleeping posture we didn't come a
sleeping posture in the much in the
podcast with Greg what you do instead of
if you get imagine I'm laid on the bed I
think I'm right tell me if I'm wrong
here you instead of having the pillow
like this you sweep the pillow down so
it's like that yeah and then you turn
over so ideally arm goes ideally you
want two pillows like that watch just
watch the video
so what Kelly care they talked about it
are you ready for me to level this up
video guardian before you leave we will
get footage of this in my bed now I have
a pregnancy pillow have you seen these
there was that you hook have you seen it
too big you it's a he
oh yeah I've seen them so although one
all that that is is something for you to
hook in between your legs on either side
something feature hook under your arm on
either side
and then you just take the arm out and
roll and go under and it's always
between your legs so I am the most
single man in the world I have a
king-size bed and there's no spare room
in it so you know what by ok what we
really have opened up the [ __ ] house
Beckett my girlfriend was having a
conversation with some people at her
work about what size beds people sleep
in yeah
because someone had said to her that a
double bed is sufficient for a couple
which is absolute horseshit like totally
agree I'm not a large man and I still
work because we don't no one like get
some bed bizarre requires no actual room
like around and you need enough room to
have like your own space and a bed what
does the zealot sleep on a single bed
all right the tiny is a lot yeah
what's the young what's this statistic
about what two single beds put together
up it's a super king I believe so a
super gets on my bed which I paid 600
pounds for the mattress just the mantras
for from Eve which is a king mm-hmm it's
still not as big as a single bed it
might may be a case two singles I don't
know reggae but in that region so what
you're saying is that a single bed gives
one person more room that the king bed
gets to so obviously you can cut into
each of this space and overlap more
effectively yeah but the effective point
they're saying is if you're anything
under what is what's one dog from a king
like Queen mm-hmm it's basically like a
GU like so yeah and then above a super
King which is so annoying I did so I
have a super king the Eve mattress do is
seven foot by seven foot bed lots of
that's a king square I was sleeping in
the Clio isn't it that means that you
could do a forward roll and you still be
not gonna fall off the bed yeah but one
of the problems there is just a knack so
the head thing the head thing and then
so that there's basically three videos
that Kelly talks about sleeping so why
is assessing the thermos any mattress so
one of the tests is lying your back at
what most people do is they default into
extension and so they bend one like so
if you lie on your mattress and
immediately bend one leg
you'll probably wake up with a sore
lower back in the morning there's a
pretty good test so you want you want to
be able to almost sit in it in a dish
this is all according to him yeah the
other one is either having so if you
can't get out of a position you can't
buy a new mattress pillow under your
hamstrings or like you say pull it or if
you're lying you so I put it between
your legs and then the other one is
should we because we've got on to being
an extension in bed should we discuss
what we were talking about just before
the podcast began let's go we're sure
we're referring to I'll let you I'll let
you take it away okay well just before
we do so this was the piggyback on
Johnny's journey sleeping one so as
unpopular as it's been with my
girlfriend I've started sleeping on the
floor recently but she slept on the
floor yeah yeah once ah see broken nose
broken it she's threatened to break up
with you genuinely upset about it I know
you want to do this but for God's sake
you don't lose your relationship good
idea yeah I didn't realize it is that
much of an issue but it really was yeah
so I've got a thin mattress topper which
was basically the reason behind that is
to protect the joints from the direct
impact with with the floor but the idea
is that when you sleep on a very soft
mattress you sink in and it's there's no
impetus to relax and so it's very easy
to maintain that tension really sleeping
which it sounds quite converse right
that something soft it doesn't help help
you in relaxing it does sound converse
and then so I suppose the the example is
you need to think of like when you if
someone gives you a massage or you get a
dentist like a dentist has to drill your
tooth or something harder than your
tooth or so what you favor or foam
rolling either using something harder
than the thing you're trying to loosen
and so when you're lying on the floor
you you have to release that tension so
that your body can shape to the floor
mm-hmm and so the idea is you do that
and it's more in line with how tribal
populations sleep and they have a much
lower incidence of musculoskeletal
injury and postural problems now yeah of
course like we do so many other
movement habits that also probably
contribute to that but we sleep for and
this was Johnny's thing to me he was
like you need to spend like you spent
the third of your life sleeping so it
makes sense to spend the most money on
your bed followed by the things workshop
on you at workstation here so I'm doing
it for a month so far five six weeks I
wake up the for my alarm every day now I
get out of bed not feeling stiff and the
only downside is like you've got a long
way to get up like you soon as you wake
up you like you can't just enjoy my
therapy yeah yours your Burpee costly
you get after you get hands and knees
and then start from that I do double
backflip right no it's something you
know steps lose appointment yeah so
sometimes I be a single if if it's like
a rough day whatever they're like yeah I
don't know how how physically get up but
I think I would roll over hands and
knees in stone but I think that's also
the way that I would do I'd want to
stand up on the mattress topper I
wouldn't want to go on a bare floor yeah
that's Slavik I'm not I'm not [ __ ]
yeah or a barbarians but see you liking
even like it in so far I'm gonna do a
video on it and like cover the full and
you also gain tanky there's a muscle
lost five kilos of fart yes and can we
talk about the extension in bed we'll
finish on this
what was the it ago but what was the
context for it it was just it's a it's
bad form I was cracking Johnny's back
yep Johnny said I look like someone
who's you look like a female who's got
poor mobility and is enjoying being
penetrated from behind in there or a dog
having a poo or dog having a poo yeah
who's the tea-things I mean when when as
a woman in a particular sexual position
you can be equated to a dog having a poo
there's that there should be some alarm
bells going but so that's it's
inefficient because you're when you know
can you example for the people that are
watching for me please
I not on YouTube I can't I I can't yes
you can there's a there's a certain
lower limit I think we're hitting a
little bit bit going into going into
flexion so lumbar flexion and tucking
the belly under under so you arched back
in on all fours
females are all riled up and said oh the
back it's it's a it's a great yoga
position but you're moving your vagina
away from whoever's trying to get in so
like animals will all go into extension
it's like it's the the natural thing but
I think we've ever written up as humans
and so I mean II and the solution
obviously it is poor mobility and and so
one of the solutions people do is they
put a pillow underneath if that if if a
woman is lying on a back but it isn't
these I mean it is you know from a guy's
perspective as well
women presumably won't know this you
don't see sex from a guy's perspective
but to see a girl inflection on all
fours is one of the least attractive
sites known to man we just think like
means wrong one you do you need to spend
a little bit more time in puppy dog
because if you're stressed
don't we all know unstop chin chin up
and through so extension extension girls
when you are all for the reason I didn't
do it because I know that Dean's gonna
make it the thumbnail of the pouch in
between okay slow-mo for 3d oculus yeah
you know we talked about leaving the
world about a place that would just that
would be a real better place that will
be leaving this podcast better than when
you found it and the way Johnny uses
Alfred
so efficiently and there's one single
domain which is he's got a bank of
pictures of me in ridiculous situations
that will just get fired out fine well
that could have been added to the
library so you protected yourself there
thank you very much for watching this I
am Ida sell them to anyone else
yeah we could do an only funds if you
have only funds
so only funds is it's like legal
softcore porn for girls that need money
for Instagram okay so you know the girls
that like a bluff photos they're like
really really suggestive you can get the
uncensored ones on only funds whatsit
and you get you get like a monthly
subscription much sure and you can pay
to chat with them as well and stuff like
that okay so yeah step away from cam
girl all right yeah one step down from
[ __ ] yourself on cameras and unit but
one bonus tip just before we go throw in
it so a boy a blender recently they're
making a lot of smoothies Parma violets
in any smoothie is incredible when you
say Parma violets describe exactly what
they look like silly they look like big
purple tablets make right so it's
exactly what I thought yeah yes this is
a look like Harry through sites like
just like a big purple red blood cell
donor thing and medicine is slowly
seeping into your life and you don't
when able to operate without there
happening at me
so Parma violets fresh mint and
pineapple
that's drink of Emma so what's the back
roads are ice cream on just one hundred
hundred hundred you gave us the other
evening like I Robin never have picked
up I made it they discontinued it and I
was so upset people since we bought them
and lemon Roman mint lime rum and mint
your own task go sometimes really I was
blown away really nice I had a little
bit of like a raisin Eli most some
things the last time any of us were ever
gonna have it what way for it to go yeah
true I mean well I'm not gonna just mean
to that forever yes Tesco if you're
watching sorted out bring it back from
for God's sake right thank you very much
for listening I have got more lifehacks
on my screen the ones I've gone through
today so 106 will probably try and get
done soon life fails needs to be done
we've got at least another five to 10
lifehacks episodes yeah well I don't
think we're ever going to be all last
they wish they were
build and he coming up yeah the optimize
mind my books I've read in the last
month
yeah do you know me yeah I think if you
have any life acts that you think that
we should feature fire in the comments
below if you're on YouTube head to
youtube if you're not and please
subscribe if you have a good Philips hue
setup and you think we're a bunch of
idiots if you want to argue with us
about the fact that smart homes aren't
for our souls fine what argue they need
them like it's bigger discussion have
yeah so fine I'll Skype you
what's got you 1v1 one thing one I swear
to god mate I will wreck you what we
gonna do next what's the next one that
we've got coming up we haven't actually
scheduled what the next topic is going
to be this second part of relationships
the relationships one or two will do
moving forward
bloody hell honesty weight training life
fails we've done lastly how to get
strong how get strong yeah you want to
do and may have you seen the CrossFit
Games have now removed regionals I saw
something about that too that chalk talk
yeah why why not read so sure they're
gonna have basically half a tiny like to
opens it looks like to kind of spread
the net a little wider and I don't
really understand if I'm honest but
there's a lot of once you go open then
like at least a second yes it's online
qualifier again basically so it allows
more people to compete at that middle
drop in there over that they drove it I
don't know anyway about the system only
PML thanks very much make sure that you
press subscribe please give me a five
star rating if you're on iTunes or
Spotify check out proper and fitness
team will make appear here and here and
here and here and here okay by them
thank you give are they
[Music]
you